Transcription: Aicha Aboukhait
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Bonsoir, bonsoir à tous.
Je suis ravie d’être ici et donc comme
tout professeur qui se respecte,
je vais vous poser des questions.
Est-ce que vous vous souvenez
de la définition de “épiclèse”,
que vous aviez appris à l’école ?
Oui, probablement pas.
Ne cherchez pas sur Google.
Par contre, est-ce que vous vous souvenez
d’un exposé
que vous aviez fait au collège ?
Oui.
Eh bien, tout est là.
En fait, on retient mieux ce qu’on fait
et ce qu’on fait par nous-mêmes.
On apprend mieux en faisant.
On apprend mieux quand on manipule,
quand nous testons, quand nous cherchons,
quand nous nous trompons,
quand nous recommençons,
quand nous expliquons à quelqu’un d’autre
et quand nous varions les approches.
Et ça, tout le monde le sait.
Le vieil adage dit : « C’est en forgeant
qu’on devient forgeron ».
Et pourtant,
souvent, à l’école,
encore trop fréquemment aujourd’hui,
on vous demande
d’apprendre en écoutant,
en regardant le professeur,
en étant silencieux,
et en recopiant.
Alors un dimanche d’après-midi d’automne,
j’ai décidé,
après des années de frustration
à voir mes élèves
apprendre très péniblement,
avec des résultats…
pas toujours satisfaisants,
de tester une méthode différente
et une approche nouvelle.
Alors, nouvelle, en fait, pas exactement
parce que ce que j’ai développé
dans mes classes de CAP
et dans mon agence de soutien scolaire
m’a été inspirée de pédagogues
du 18ᵉ, 19ᵉ,
et 20ᵉ siècle
dont j’ignorais jusque-là les travaux,
alors que j’enseignais déjà
depuis plus de dix ans.
Où étaient ces pédagogues
dans les années où je me formais
pour devenir enseignante ?
Où étaient ces pédagogies
dans les concours d’entrée
à l’Éducation nationale ?
Où étaient ces pédagogie
dans la formation
continue des enseignants ?
Invisibles.
Encore aujourd’hui,
quand je me déplace
dans les établissements
pour former des professeurs à la pédagogie
de la classe autonome,
plus de la moitié d’entre eux disent
ne pas connaître ces pédagogies,
ou très peu.
Il y a même des universités en France
où les étudiants en train de se préparer
pour devenir professeurs,
qui passent le CAPES,
on leur Interdit, on leur déconseille
de parler de ces pédagogues.
Et c’est pourtant en appuyant
ma réflexion sur leurs travaux
et sur mon expérience et mon intuition
du terrain que j’ai développé une classe
où les élèves apprennent avec plaisir, en
bougeant, en manipulant, en s’entraidant,
et en s’auto corrigeant.
Alors comment elle fonctionne
cette méthode ?
Vous allez voir.
C’est très simple,
elle est divisée en trois temps.
Le premier temps, c'est un temps
dit de cours classique.
Je suis devant ma classe, je fais cours,
je montre des documents,
je pose des questions, j’interagis avec
mes élèves, ils interagissent avec moi.
Vous allez me dire oui, super.
Il n’y a rien de nouveau là dedans.
Il n’y a rien de révolutionnaire, non ?
Sauf que la différence, c'est que
ça ne dure que 25% du temps.
Un quart seulement du temps de cours
est consacré au professeur
qui parle et qui enseigne.
Un quart.
Deuxième temps
c’est un temps de vérification.
Donc, on fait un petit questionnaire
et ça permet d’ancrer la connaissance.
Et le troisième temps,
c’est le temps des ateliers.
Donc, chaque élève dispose d'une liste
d'ateliers qu'il peut faire dans l'ordre
qu’il souhaite et autant de fois
qu’il le souhaite.
Il peut se lever, il peut décider
de travailler avec son camarade.
Il peut…
Ils peuvent s'entraider.
Ils peuvent se poser des questions.
Ils s’entraînent l’un l’autre
sur le jeu des flashcards
pour apprendre les définitions.
Par exemple, ils vont regarder une vidéo
sur la vie des Français
au temps de la Révolution française.
Ils vont replacer sur une carte les pays
du Moyen-Orient avec des petits drapeaux
qu'ils vont planter sur une carte.
Et ils vont apprendre
la chronologie des présidents
de la cinquième République
avec des poupées russes.
Et ce temps de manipulation,
ce temps où l’élève il fait, il apprend
en faisant, il apprend en manipulant
et en s’auto corrigeant,
ça dure 50 % du temps de la classe
et ça ressemble à ça.
J’aimerais juste préciser que je travaille
en CFA, c’est-à-dire que j’ai
des CAP et des BP brevet professionnel,
classe de boulangers, bouchers,
charcutiers, pâtissiers,
chocolatiers, poissonniers.
C’est des gens qui n’aiment pas l’école
pour la plupart, qui ont été brisés
par le système scolaire.
Et ils ont surtout pas envie de faire
de l'histoire géographie.
Cette vidéo ?
Moi, personnellement,
je ne sais pas vous,
mais ça me fait rêver
en tant que professeur.
En fait, 50% du temps,  le professeur
a fabriqué son environnement,
il a pensé ses ateliers,
il a créé son matériel et il laisse
le matériel devenir l’enseignant.
Lorsque j’ai vu pour la première fois
la classe autonome fonctionner
devant mes yeux, j’y ai à peine cru.
Et lorsque j’ai vu les retours des élèves
et les premiers résultats,
arrivaient les premières notes,
mais c’est devenu une évidence
pour moi. Il fallait à tout prix
diffuser cette méthode.
Mais qui allait m’écouter ?
Professeure du CFA de province
non certifiée,
recalée des concours
de l’Éducation nationale,
enseignant à des classes de CAP.
J'étais invisible à mon tour.
J'étais inaudible même.
Et pourtant, je savais.
Je voyais que cette méthode,
elle sauvait des élèves au quotidien.
Alors je l’ai défendu,
ce travail dont la pédagogie autonome
n’était qu’une partie.
J'ai défendu mon travail corps et âme,
jusqu'au jour ou celui ci a été reconnu
par un jury international
de professionnels du monde de l’éducation,
avec ma nomination parmi les dix
finalistes à travers le monde en lice
pour recevoir le prestigieux
Global Teacher Prize.
Mais ça, vous connaissez, bien sûr.
Non ?
Eh bien, c'est normal.
Parce que ce prix, il est aussi invisible,
parfois, et notamment en France.
Beaucoup de professeurs
ignorent son existence.
Et pourtant, c'est un prix qui vient
récompenser le travail de professeurs
passionnés à travers le monde,
qui développent des pédagogies innovantes
et des projets inspirants
pour aider les élèves
sur le terrain
dans le monde entier.
En fait, c’est le prix Nobel
de l’éducation ou le prix Nobel,
l'équivalent pour les enseignants.
Et cette nomination m’a donné une voix
pour parler de cette méthode qui a changé
ma vie et celle de mes élèves.
Parce qu'avec la classe autonome, ils sont
plus épanouis, ils sont plus motivés,
ils sont plus concentrés,
ils s’entraident, ils apprennent mieux,
ils retiennent mieux, ils s’ennuient
moins, et les notes augmentent.
Avec la classe autonome, on redonne
l'envie, l'envie d'apprendre, le plaisir.
Mais on apprend aussi la rigueur,
la responsabilité, la persévérance,
l'entraide et l'auto évaluation.
Alors, je sais ce que vous allez me dire
et je l’entends très très souvent.
C'est trop beau pour être vrai.
C'est impossible.
Les classes sont trop hétérogènes.
Je vous présente ma classe
de CAP Boulanger.
On va me dire que c’est impossible
parce que les classes sont trop chargées.
J’ai rencontré récemment une professeur
qui m’a dit faire de la classe autonome
dans des classes de 37 élèves
avec un franc succès.
Impossible, on n’a pas les moyens.
Impossible.
Mes élèves sont trop dissipés,
trop difficiles à mettre,
dans des quartiers compliqués,
dans des milieux des collèges ZEP ou REP
J’ai testé cette pédagogie
sur une classe de 26 CAP bouchers.
Je répète, 26 CAP bouchers.
On va me dire que c’est impossible
parce que c’est facile à faire en CAP.
Mais c’est impossible à mettre au lycée
sur des programmes beaucoup
plus denses, beaucoup plus complexes,
ou encore dans le supérieur.
Ça, c’est du matériel que j’utilise pour
préparer mes élèves à la dissertation,
au baccalauréat de français, mais aussi
pour la philosophie en terminale
ou encore pour les spécialités
géopolitiques
mais aussi pour la SES, la SVT.
Ça s’adapte à toute matière
et à tout niveau et j’ai des professeurs,
en France aujourd’hui qui commencent
à le tester en licence, en BTS,
avec vraiment un un franc succès.
Et puis la dernière chose qu’on me dit,
que c’est du ludique, ça ne marche pas,
L’élève n’apprend pas vraiment
Voici les notes de mes élèves au bac
de français l'année dernière.
Alors je vous pose la question.
Combien de temps continuerons-nous
à dire que c’est impossible ?
Juste parce que ça nous gêne,
que ça nous demande de sortir
de notre zone de confort,
que ça nous demande de revoir
notre façon de penser,
de refaire nos cours, de changer
notre posture d’enseignant.
Combien de temps encore
pour que ces pédagogies
rentrent dans la formation des enseignants
parce qu’elles sont efficaces
et elles sont adaptables
à toute matière et à tout niveau ?
Combien de temps encore
on va faire la sourde oreille
face à des professeurs de terrain
qui apportent des réponses concrètes
aux problèmes du mal-être à l’école.
Parce que des initiatives comme celle-là,
il en a des dizaines de milliers
en France,
qui sont elles aussi invisibles.
Et si la réponse face à l’échec scolaire,
face à la souffrance à l’école,
face à l’ennui en cours, elle était
simplement dans une pédagogie
qui demande de changer de philosophie.
Juste ça, juste changer de philosophie.
Pourquoi l’école
devrait-elle faire souffrir ?
Pourquoi apprendre,
ça devrait être une épreuve douloureuse ?
Pourquoi, à notre arrivée au lycée,
on n’aurait plus envie de pédagogie
active, ludique, colorée ?
Pourquoi penser systématiquement
que ce sont les élèves qui ont des lacunes
alors que c’est peut-être nos méthodes
qui n’ont pas été adaptées ?
Je crois profondément aujourd’hui
dans la méthode de la classe autonome.
Je pense qu’en changeant nos méthodes,
on peut redonner
une place à tout le monde.
On peut redonner sa chance et on peut
rétablir une vraie égalité à l'école.
Et je pense sincèrement que cette méthode
peut s'adapter à tout niveau
et à toute matière.
La pédagogie, ça devrait être
le cœur de notre métier.
Ça devrait être le socle
de la formation des enseignants.
Et tant qu’on recrutera les professeurs
avant tout sur l’érudition
et trop peu sur la pédagogie,
eh bien, notre école, elle sera
toujours en souffrance.
Qui aujourd’hui, avec ce qu’on sait
sur les neurosciences, sur le cerveau,
peut encore se dire qu’on doit faire
des cours magistraux,
faire écrire les élèves
sous la dictée pendant des heures.
C’est pourtant ce dont témoignent
de nombreux élèves encore aujourd’hui.
Mais il faut changer cela.
Il faut remettre la pédagogie au centre.
La pédagogie ne doit plus être invisible.
Car si l’éducation est l’arme
la plus efficace qu’on puisse utiliser
pour changer le monde, la pédagogie
représente nos munitions.
Et la dernière question
qui reste en suspens,
et je vois que vous réfléchissez
depuis tout à l’heure.
Que veut dire ce satané mot d’épiclèse ?
Alors, si je vous donnais la réponse,
je serais en totale contradiction
avec tout ce que je viens
de vous expliquer.
Donc je vous laisserai donc chercher
la réponse par vous-même.
Merci.